des philippe froguel chercheur
généticien et professeur à l'impérial
collège de londres et à l'université
lille ii bonjour philippe froguel merci
de répondre à nos questions qu'est ce
qu'on sait exactement de cette nouvelle
souche il ya des touches chaque fois
chaque jour parce qu'on réalise ces
virus à arn mult beaucoup c'est bien
connu pour les russes de la grippe
celle ci est inquiétante parce qu'elle a
une mutation certaines correspondant
aussi d'entrée laisse du virus dans la
cellule humaine et d'autres peut-être
encore plus inquiétante au niveau de la
production d'une protéine qui s'appelle
spike et justement la protéine qui est
visé par les vaccins actuels ceux de
pfizer et de modern art donc c'est
normal qu'ils aient une inquiétude en
france
ce qui est ennuyeux c'est qu'on n'a pas
du tout fait comme en angleterre et ne
séquence pas systématiquement les sushis
avec l'exception de liège sud de
marseille
donc je ne suis pas sûr qu'on soit
capable de savoir facilement et
rapidement ce qui se passe ce qui se
passe en france
quant à éviter que le virus dissémine
l'angleterre à la france un peu
illusoire moi j'étais dans l'eurostar
vendredi c'était bondé et ce quelqu'un
est un peu de paix là bas je vois pas
comment on va vraiment empêché essadi
féminin français justement de parler de
la france donc l'angleterre l'italie
l'autriche la suisse confine au moins en
partie les pays-bas réagissent également
la france est en couvre feu nocturne est
ce qu'elle est à contre-courant et à ce
qu'elle prend des risques sachant qu'il
y aurait donc une nouvelle souche la
france ont des mesures qui correspondent
à ce qui se passe aujourd'hui est ce que
la population et texte est capable
d'accepter en tout cas veut veut
accepter est sûr que on le sait très
bien les fêtes vont faire un brassage de
population donc de virus et si
effectivement cette souche arrive
d'angleterre ce qui est quand même très
probable et se dissémine beaucoup plus
facilement on risque d'avoir une très
grosse augmentation des cas début
janvier et là il va falloir des
agir de d'abord des fameux tests massif
on peut être un grand succès j'espère
que se doivent de roubaix fonctionnant
mieux il faut vraiment savoir où on en
est et puis comme je viens de le dire il
faut conséquent ces souches
on ne fait pas beaucoup en france et on
fasse une surveillance très précise
parce que si cette souche là est
vraiment la plus contagieuse
il va falloir essayer de les isoler les
populations petit baume de manière
géographiques comme l'angleterre à faire
pas toute la france et et accélérer
l'arrivée des vaccins donc une souche
donc plus contagieuse qui serait selon
certains experts un peu contagieuse à
70%
mais est-ce qu'elle est plus virulente
cette souche et puis quid des vaccins
est ce que cette mutation peut remettre
en cause l'efficacité des précieux sérum
alors pour cela la virulence ses bases
et simplement sur le fait qu'il ya un
rebond d'épidémie à londres se rédige
j'étais à londres dans la semaine j'ai
bien vu que les anglais faisait part
très attention notamment dans le métro
dans la rue donc association corrélation
veut pas dire effectivement une
causalité il va falloir attendre et voir
réellement si c'est fait avec l'histoire
de kloster est ce que les gens qui ont
ce virus-là entraîne plus de clusters
que ceux qui ont une autre souche
quant à la dangerosité de la de la
souche pour l'instant il n'y a aucun
signe inquiétant et non pas un paon pas
non plus de signe inquiétant de
résistance au virus
cela dit il va peut-être falloir que
rapport au vaccin va peut-être falloir
qu'il change un petit peu le les vaccins
pendant les prochains mois si
effectivement virus change avec sarens à
la hausse à la propriété des traces il a
changé donc si dans trois mois dans six
mois il faut changer de file search en
chemin son vaccin ça veut dire que les
personnes qui vont se faire vacciner
prochainement à partir du 27 décembre
potentiellement il ne serait pas protégé
face à cette nouvelle souche c'est ça il
devrait donc se re faire vacciner encore
après pour l'instant on n'a aucun moyen
de savoir ce qu'est ce qui va se passer
et aucune indication que les personnes
qui sont vaccinées en ce moment qui
seront vaccinés en janvier seront plus
ou moins résistantes à l'infection donc
mais il va falloir surveiller ça c'est
un peu comme la grippe la grippe virus
change beaucoup et et les industriels du
médicament modifié en fonction les
vaccins donc il faut une surveillance
très près comment se créent ces
mutations du virus est ce qu'il faut en
attendre encore durant l'hiver voire
même après les virus change tout le
temps
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que ce virus là
qui devait quelque part est arrivé vers
l'homme c'est parce que il est devenu
acceptable pour les cellules pulmonaires
men il changera et plus il se dissémine
dans la population humaine plus il mute
comme comme tout organisme vivant
et là il faut s'attendre à des
changements à ce que ces changements
vont avoir des effets ce que le virus
sera plus ou moins dangereux pour
l'homme c'est à dire plus ou moins
mortel et est ce que cela va modifier
les vaccins la n'oublions pas qu'il ya
d'autres vaccins qui vont arriver à qui
sont pas des vaccins et rennes et avec
les et 4,5 vaccin on devrait avoir au
début de l'année il n'aura bien eux qui
seront qu'ils seront efficaces mais pour
l'instant je répète on n'a aucun moyen
de savoir si cette mutation de ce virus
a le moindre effet sur l'efficacité des
vaccins
dernière question philippe raud gueule
quand on voit les chiffres liés à
l'épidémie quand on voit cette
vail souche également du nouveau courant
d'un virus est-ce qu'on un troisième
confinement début janvier est probable
en france selon vous aujourd'hui il la
question de savoir s'il ya une troisième
vague on n'est pas vraiment sorti de la
deuxième on l'a on le voit bien il est
possible que ces deuxième vague on
l'appelle deuxième ou troisième
reprennent en janvier les ai
effectivement les fêtes de noël plus
peut-être cette histoire de nouvelles
souches vous faire flamber comme ça
s'est passé aux états unis et dans
beaucoup d'autres pays
moi je serais pas étonné que fin janvier
ou en février
on se retrouve dans une situation à
présent milieu zay qui va falloir
recommencer des mesures de confinement
et ses mesures de confinement héros de
confinement et déconfinement elles vont
durer tant qu'on n'aura pas assez de
virus par don de vaccins pour tuer le
virus
et puis pour stopper ces vagues à
répétition merci philippe rogle d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes chercheur généticien et
professeurs également à l'impérial
college de londres notamment